how are they finding it very difficult
to run your entire operation when I've
never ever actually seen two weeks in
Los Angeles you're working for Howard
Hughes no harm having high hopes ma'am
mr. Hughes the White House is calling
you are you not in the desert with me
is it not hot enough for the desert
where do I put 350 gallons of ice cream
get any idea how many houses he has
practices under contract something like
14 more like 22 more like 26
mr. Jews wants to see mr. Hughes I'd
like to thank you thank you for my
acting classes thank you for the house
thank you for the paycheck and thank you
for the chance to become a star roll
film and I'm not insulted by your
failure to meet me sooner because I know
you have your own way of doing things
yeah yeah that's good I hired you as my
double because you look exactly like me
mr. Hughes you look wonderful I think
you say you you still feel Howard Hughes
is going to be interested in developing
a housing project with a kid your age
mr. Hughes Victor Hugo once said there's
nothing so powerful as an idea whose
time has come
has that banana nut banana nut sir yeah
this game Howard Hughes plays with young
women it doesn't fool me one bit
nobody's getting any younger
if anybody working for me wants to
strike up a relationship with one of our
contract actresses I have to fire it
what are you doing you've got a driver's
license don't you
you think I'm nuts right I really think
you need help
Oh get that person out of here have you
heard from people that I'm crazy you're
not crazy you're an exception you make
an old guy courageous Marla I am finally
gonna do something that I haven't done
for far too long he knows he can't fly I
think it may have a doors to that but
this is Frank's first plane ride I want
to make it that much
the Virgin Wireless emerged some guys
never stopped looking to hide the salami
what do the deed dip the wick butter the
muffin and get it